I feel more like a creative artist using  photography because there's the digital  work is so interesting now so the first  word for you is artists not pornography  thank you yes I would I would like that  an artist who uses a camera that's your  brush that's your pen it's come to that  I I have had many different stages of  photography as there are many different  ways to take photographs but I feel now  I am I'm in that stage of my life where  I use the camera you know in that way I  think you have said this and I hope you  have me do the way you welcome age and  learn from age I have said that I I  think it's not talked about enough how  interesting it is  - I really do and I'm you know yeah it  is really exciting and and it doesn't  mean you're gonna necessarily take a  better photograph but you know what  you're doing and is the Isha's it's just  great I love it I just love it